it was a coup for Marvel's movies when
Award winner Anthony Hopkins agreed to
join the MCU as Odin Thor's father and
king of Asgard while he seems like an
obvious pick for the role he wasn't the
only actor in the running for the all
father in an interview with the guardian
Mel Gibson explained that he was asked
to play Odin but as he succinctly put it
I didn't do it at first glance the
action star seems like an odd pick to
play the stately Norse God but with a
solid background in Shakespearean
theater Gibson probably would have felt
comfortable with Odin's aristocratic
dialogue of course with all the
controversies surrounding the actor it
was probably best for the MCU that
Gibson turned down the part